nike collaborating with kobe bryant's
widow that's vanessa the company plans
to release a new sneaker to honor the
bryant's daughter gianna also known as
gigi who died in the 2020 helicopter
crash that also killed a basketball star
and seven other people now the shoe is
going to be called
kobe 6 pro tro
mambasita sweet 16. i like it all
proceeds will benefit the mamba and
mambasita sports foundation which pays
for sports programs in underserved
communities vanessa bryant and nike will
also work together to establish a youth
basketball center in southern california
this seems like such a fitting tribute
for all of the parties involved it's
nice to see i like this collaboration
will i be able to get a pair that's the
question
i want to know if am i going to get here
they're going to go like hotkeys
what can we call
i wear a size 10 which i can wear
great job by nike though great job and
there's two of them together too we
always think about vanessa and her
children
wonderful wonderful i love that